that I'm not a robot click thing
actually works because I I actually
don't know how that's how it works but I
think it has to do with the movement of
the mouse the timing and they know that
it's very difficult for currently for a
bot to mimic human behavior in the way
they would click that little checkbox
yeah exactly I think it's something I
mean uh again my recollection on that is
it's like a pile of Highly obfuscated
JavaScript with all kind it looks like a
very simple box but it's doing a lot of
stuff and it's collecting all kinds of
instrumentation and yeah exactly like a
like a robot is just a little too
deterministic or if it's got noise it's
like gaussian noise and the way humans
do it is just not something that you
need to be able to do without collecting
thousands and thousands and thousands of
human traces doing it but it is a
predator prey on that well and then the
computer or billions of human traces I
don't know the computer just sees the
JavaScript it needs to be able to
look outside the simulation for the
computer the world is like right it
doesn't the computer doesn't know about
the physical world it has to look
outside of its world and introspect back
on this simple box right is which is
kind of you know I think that's exactly
what mushrooms do or like psychedelics
is you get to go outside and look back
in and that's what a computer needs to
do I you know I do wonder whether they
actually give people Insight or whether
they give people the illusion of insight
uh is there a difference yeah because uh
well actual Insight you know actual
Insight is
again Maxwell's equations you're able to
shift the world with that there's a lot
of practical devices that work the
illusion of insight is
I'm Jesus Christ and nothing happens
right so I don't know I think this is
quite different uh I don't know I I
think you can fake it till you make it
on that one which is
um Insight in some sense is revealing a
truth that was there all along